as you may already know we're dedicating
most of our broadcast next Wednesday to
a live special focusing on mental health
it's gonna be called stop the stigma a
conversation about mental health and we
want to remove the shame and blame from
the discussion around mental illness
diagnosis this morning as part of our
commitment to tackling issues
surrounding mental health we're looking
at post-traumatic stress about 8 million
adults experienced it during any given
year and our lead national correspondent
David Wagner shows us a powerful play
written and performed by military
veterans it is called last out and David
is here to help us understand it all
good morning good morning so this is a
play that caters not only to people in
the audience but also to those on stage
who are putting it on right wherever you
are watching this just pause for a
moment I want you to be able to sort of
reflect and see what we saw when we went
to watch the play in Chicago this is put
on by a man who spent more than 20 years
in the service and in dealing with his
own pts decided to write a play watch
this we did an easel down stevie's what
you're working on that's me
has your time in the service affected
your mental health yes it has for a lot
of years I pushed down a lot of the
aspects of combat that I didn't
understand whether it was survivor's
guilt or mood swings or a lot of the the
indicators of post-traumatic stress I
pushed him down because I wanted to stay
in the fight Scott Mann was a u.s. army
green beret who got deployed 12 times in
11 years he's retired as a lieutenant
colonel you can save your own life you
let those boys go or your own father's
gonna kill you nice and slow
his story is told on the stage finish
this sentence for me this play for me
is a way to heal yeah it's I did I
didn't know that when I started and and
maybe that's a little bit selfish but
that's just what came came up when you
said that that's what it's been for me
is it's it's been an opportunity to you
just deal with and process and face a
lot of the things that I was struggling
to either talk about or to express and
Danny the play he wrote and stars in is
all about the trauma of war I saw dr.
Diego this week and he said that's
normal for post-traumatic stress
that'll get me pulled off this
deployment what this is about it's about
me being faster no this is about you
calling the doc that'll get me pulled
off this deployment maybe when I get
back
promise me we'll see we gotta do
something baby you're grinding you
molars into a dust I'm good no you're
not I'm not used to seeing people like
you'd be so vulnerable that makes two of
us two things three things for you
our director aim she said because it's
three combat veterans and and didn't aim
as a military family member so one of
the things that she said to us right out
of the gate in war if you're horrible
you get killed but on a stage every time
you have an eagle down I'm back here
putting the nets back into the tree look
you what's your target audience when I
started it was civilians who I felt like
didn't understand fully that we were 18
years into this war my oldest son Cody
was three when the towers fell he'll be
an army lieutenant next year likely
going over to fight the war that I
didn't finish
there are several scenes in the play
which can trigger flashbacks
Richard promised a downside cone I'm
telling you we saw it happen to Scot on
stage at a rehearsal that man treating
him and this crew member is Diego
Hernandez he is a clinical therapist who
travels with the show and even treats
members of the audience while we were
there Dan Miller's heart rate increased
rapidly as he was watching the play his
SmartWatch alerted paramedics he is a
fifty year old former Marine whose
post-traumatic stress was triggered once
the paramedics cleared him Diego
Hernandez treated him when talking about
post-traumatic stress Diego and Scott
man intentionally leave off the D for
disorder we need to take the D off we
need to start treating this thing like
an injury not an illness so that these
very very high performing people can get
back in the game and lead us because we
need them all these guys gone and you
want me to just let go yes I do Danny
this isn't your foot level it doesn't
matter cuz I gotta sit right there's no
other way out the more committed we are
to this story the more the veterans just
settle in and you can just feel them
going for the ride and when it's over
you just see the look in their eyes you
know that it was just hey thanks for
telling my story man you know it's just
that and you know you did right by them
you know treating the people who were
triggered as they watched the play was
really the most powerful part you know
Hernandez averages about five pts
outreaches per city that's more than 160
since the show began and the outreach
continues tonight as the show begins a
run of three performances of last out in
Cincinnati it's really cathartic it
seems for all involved and I think he
makes a really good point which I
thought of until he said it
about taking off the D yeah yeah that's
another that's another form of stigma
really when you think about it it likes
ordering it like an injury they can't be
rehabilitated so you can move on alright
David thank you so much and you can join
us next Wednesday for our live special
stop the stigma conversation about
mental health issue will include queer I
star and mental health advocate karamo
will also be joined by people who have
personal experience with mental illness
and by experts in the field over the
next week celebrities and other
high-profile folks are among those
sharing their stories on our digital
platforms today former Missouri
Secretary of State Jason Kander tells us
about his experience with post-traumatic
stress following military service